[Music]
hey guys it's me Eddie remember any word
that maths teacher guy if you gotta say
I wanted to talk to you about Australian
citizenship but before I do I just
wanted to loop in some my friends just
hold on Australian citizenship means a
lot to me it means diversity it means
inclusion and of course it means
acceptance so maybe citizenship means
being part of a big growing
multicultural team that values men and
women equally and respects our
difference what being an Australian
citizen means to me is that you are now
living in a country that is home to the
oldest surviving cultures in the world
to me being Australian is about having
the courage to give things a go and also
to be inclusive and give everyone to go
what does it mean to be Australian what
here for each other
can you for our children being
Australian to me
is about respecting each other no matter
who you are or where you come from
Australians believe in equality fairness
and freedom and we also like to have fun
the values that Australians share is the
fact that we are all the same there is
no race as I say apart from the human
race Australia's enriched by new
citizens blood the fact that they bring
new meaning new culture and a new
element to what we call being an
Australian in contemporary Australian
society with every new citizen our
beautiful rich diversity grows even
bigger there is nothing more wonderful
than watching the children of Australia
from so many different backgrounds
dreaming of what their future is going
to be my message to all our new
Australians is to soak it up we are in a
beautiful country that has so much
privilege and learn all you can about
the richness of all indigenous
Australian cultures I'm sure respect and
care for all of these give twenty of
them so they can create the newest roam
explore this finest and beautiful
country and be adventurous let's use
Australian citizenship to show the world
where
well guys thank you so much for sharing
your thoughts Australian citizenship it
really is amazing talk to you guys soon
bye
[Music]
you